President Trump arrived back in the US
after his historic summit with North
Korean leader Kim jong-un Air Force one
landed at Joint Base Andrews in Maryland
this morning the president tweeted after
the long flight from Singapore everybody
can now feel much safer than the day I
took office he also added there is no
longer a nuclear threat from North Korea
but the president faces questions about
a White House made video shown to Kim
and what's not in the agreement that the
two leaders sign weecha Jang is at the
White House with more on that part of
the story we should good morning good
morning Gail all those questions is
because that document is just a vague
outline that does not provide any
groundbreaking promises about deed
nuclearization but president Trump says
he is so confident he will do better
than his predecessors because he's the
one doing the deal-making president
Trump landed in Washington early this
morning after his whirlwind trip with
kim jeong-hoon in singapore on his way
back to the White House the president
tweeted before taking off his people
were assuming that we were going to war
with North Korea no longer sleep well
tonight
the two nation's leaders signed a joint
statement committing to complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
with no mention of verification a
timeline or North Korea's human rights
abuses the president's announcement that
joint military exercises between the
u.s. and South Korea would come to an
end that concession caught senior
Pentagon officials and Seoul off-guard
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo who
briefed Japanese and South Korean
officials immediately after the summit
is scheduled to meet with South Korea's
president moon jae-in and Chinese
President Xi Jinping on Thursday and on
Capitol Hill vice president Mike Pence
briefed GOP senators the president says
he wants congressional approval for a
deal but lawmakers on both sides
questioned Kim's sincerity kim
jeong-hoon
working with him is like trying an
thievish are and the agreement this
amounts to nothing more at this point
than a photo op out of the dermis can
come the light as part of the effort to
convince him to give up his nuclear
weapons their story is well known but
what the National Security Council
created more than four minutes of
tailored multimedia content which was
played out before the president's press
conference two men two leaders one
destiny depicting a prosperous Pyongyang
alongside the United States I showed it
to him today actually during the meeting
toward the end of the meeting and I
think he loved it destiny pictures the
production company mentioned in that
video says it had nothing to do with it
meanwhile President Trump continues to
insist he has not given anything up
pointing to kim's pledge that he will
destroy a missile engine testing site
and returned the remains of fallen u.s.
heroes as proof that the u.s. got the
better end of the deal in Singapore Nora
we should thank you I had no idea the
National Security Council could produce
videos like that